another date date night for you guys
honestly there's we've had so many date
nights we don't even know what to do
with ourselves anymore we're like all
right screw date night what this is too
much you need a break from each other we
need to hang out sit on the couch for a
second he's proud of you this is a big
deal for you producer you star in this
film in the movie your character is very
inspiring and encouraging to Jason's
character so I'm wondering in real life
how are you inspiring and encouraging
for your husband for Justin you really
would have to ask him I don't know I
just basically boss them around all the
time do this fix that make boy take the
garbage out come on get it together wake
up don't go to sleep
stay awake he says yes honey yeah I
don't know I got I hope I'm inspiring to
him I mean I think having a partner who
who is doing something that you're
excited about like for me his music and
everything that he does it's just it's
amazing to see somebody doing what they
love and I think it can be as simple as
that really and I'm sure he loves saying
you do what you love to yes because it
makes us happy as human beings as
individuals I mean it's wonderful to be
parents and it's wonderful to give to
your families and everything but it's
also important to be a person and to be
an independent human and do things that
make you happy because if you're not
happy then your kids aren't happy and
your husband isn't happy and your family
isn't happy it's not worth it speaking
of happy kids how do the stylists think
about you guys get dressed up for the
Globes and out here tonight he was just
interested in Thomas the Train he was
like okay I'm playing trains but you
guys go do what you're gonna do it can
leave me alone now I was like
you